-Our next guest is a very
funny comedian and actor
you know from "The Daily Show"
and movies
like "Crazy Rich Asians"
and "M3GAN."
He's currently performing
stand-up across the country
on the
"Love to Hate It Tour,"
including this Saturday
at Radio City Music Hall.
Please welcome to the show,
Ronny Chieng, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome. How are you?
-Thank you!
Thanks for having me!
-I'm so thrilled
to have you here.
-What an institution
to be here, man.
I've been watching you forever.
-Well, I really appreciate that.
I've been a big fan
of everything you're doing.
And it's a very exciting
new chapter at "The Daily Show"
that's starting.
Jon Stewart is coming back
to host on Monday.
-Yeah, yeah. Jon Stewart's back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then the correspondents
are going to host
from Tuesdays to Thursdays.
This has to be really exciting.
-Yeah. It's great.
Who better to take over the show
than the guy
who invented the show?
-Yeah.
Yeah, the guy who pioneered
modern American satire.
So, he's back. He's back.
-As choices go,
it's a pretty easy one to make.
-Yeah, it only took a more
than a calendar year
to make that choice,
so there you go.
-It does -- It is funny
that it took a calendar year
to come back to the last guy
who had the job.
-Yeah, I know.
So, great decision-making.
-Certainly, it was
in great hands in the years
in between, with Trevor Noah
and the rest of you.
Congratulations.
You won the Emmy last week.
-Yes, we won the Emmy
with Trevor Noah.
He's my guy, Trevor. Noah.
-There you go.
-He's the reason I was able
to come to America.
I love Trevor. Emmy deserved.
And, you know,
it's such a -- It's --
You know,
I grew up in Malaysia,
and I'm such a fan
of American institutions,
just like yourself.
And who knew?
Who knew that one day,
I could come to America,
come to New York City, do
comedy, join "The Daily Show,"
be in the same Emmy category
as you and defeat you...
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're the best show.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-This show.
-That proves it.
-We won. We're the champions.
Love it or hate it, we won.
We're the better show.
We're objectively
the better late-night show.
Yeah. Yeah.
Boo. Boo all you want.
-I'm gonna take this away.
-No, we got to keep this going.
We got to start
beef between the shows.
That's how -- Come on.
Say some [bleep]
-I don't want beef with you.
-This is how we
save our networks.
We got to talk [bleep]
about each other's show.
I'm trying to start
late-night war.
Let's go. Late-night wars!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is why I moved
to America for --
for late-night-talk-show drama.
We have a strong history of
late-night-talk-show drama
in this country,
all the way from Carson
to Letterman to Conan and Leno.
We gotta keep this going,
alright?
-Yeah, there's a
lack of beef right now.
-Yeah. I'll start.
-Alright, you start. Go.
-I'll start the beef, okay?
I'm going to say
some [bleep] about this.
"Late Night with Seth Meyers" --
this show is on too late.
-Yeah, you're right.
-Okay? If you're watching
this live, go to bed!
Go to bed.
-Okay, your turn, your turn.
Go, go.
-This show is on too late.
-Yeah, that's why we won the --
Oh, wait.
-I want to say, because you have
gotten in trouble for your --
Sometimes, you speak your mind,
like you just did.
-Sure.
-You hosted
the International Emmy Awards.
I'm going to tell you a secret.
I did this once, too.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
It's just a hotel
down the street.
It's literally
a hotel in Midtown.
-Yes, yes.
-The International Emmy Awards.
And it's a really wacky gig.
-It is, and we are
in the alumni of people
who have hosted
the International Emmys.
John Oliver also hosted it.
Before I took the gig,
I asked him if I should do it.
He said, "Go ahead."
Be clear --
International Emmys, big deal
for -- as someone who
doesn't come from America,
who respects American
show business.
-Of course.
-Big deal for
all the participants involved.
-And great shows, I will say.
-Great shows.
I will probably not get
to host it again, though.
-Okay.
Thank you for your honesty.
-Because -- No, I don't think
they'll have me back,
because when I hosted it,
the one time I hosted it,
we had, like,
a "La La Land" incident.
So, I'm hosting the show.
I come out. I do a bit.
Part of the introduction is,
I introduce the accountants
from the top-four --
one of the top-four
accounting firms in the --
I can't remember which one.
-As long as it was top four,
I don't care.
-Right.
It's one of the top four.
And I'm like, "Oh,
these guys are in charge of
auditing the votes,
making sure
the winners are legit.
Give it up
for these accountants."
And everyone's like,
"Yeah, accountants."
And then I introduced
John Turturro
to present the first award.
So then John Turturro comes out.
He's supposed
to present the award
for -- I can't remember what.
Like, it was TV Movie.
And he opens the --
He reads out the nominees,
he opens the winner envelope,
and he reads out a name
that is not any of the nominees.
And it turns out he announced
the winner for the Best Drama,
which is the last award, yeah.
So he ruined the whole suspense
of the whole thing.
And, you know,
it's not his fault.
He was just reading.
And he goes,
"I just read the thing.
I didn't..."
And then he goes offstage, and
Lou Diamond Phillips was there.
It was a thing.
And then I come out
after that and I go,
"These [bleep] accountants.
You guys had one --
You had job
and you messed it up."
And no one was happy about that,
so I don't think --
I don't think I'll get a chance
to host the International Emmys
again, but...
-One of the things I've been
very excited to meet you --
and tonight's the first night
we're meeting --
is you mentioned
you're from Malaysia,
and then you came
to the States as a kid
and then Singapore
and then Australia.
But in the States,
you were in my hometown.
You were in
Manchester, New Hampshire.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And you were a kid --
younger, obviously, than I am.
But what was your take on
"ManchVegas" back in the day?
-Yeah, Manchester,
New Hampshire -- it was --
So, my parents went to college
very late in life.
They had two kids
and then they went to college --
in Malaysia.
And then they went to college
and they put themselves
through college in Manchester,
New Hampshire, with two kids,
and they got their master's.
And then we were good
immigrants, 'cause after we got
what we wanted, we went home.
We didn't take anyone's job.
We didn't --
You know, we were like,
"Okay, we're going back."
And then so
we went back after that.
And, so, I was away.
I lived in Manchester,
New Hampshire, for like --
was it 3 to 8?
So about four or five years.
And then I went back
to Malaysia.
And when I was in Malaysia
and living in Singapore,
the whole time,
I'm like, "I need to go back.
I need to go back
to Manchester, New Hampshire."
It's just in my head.
It was this magical place
where there was snow
and you could leave
your car unlocked.
And there was like --
there was like one restaurant
and, you know --
And then I managed
to come back years later,
after I joined "The Daily Show."
So it took me 25 years to
get back to
Manchester, New Hampshire.
And I was so psyched to --
I did a college gig
at one of
the universities there.
I went to go visit
my old elementary school,
Webster Elementary,
and I went to go visit the park
and the river and, like,
the three places I knew.
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"Oh, this is actually
a very random place to be."
-Yeah.
-I had no idea when I was a kid.
I thought this was
the whole world.
-Yeah.
-But now I go back as an adult,
and I'm like,
"Why were we here?"
-Yeah.
-There was nowhere else? Really?
But -- Yeah, but I love
New Hampshire.
-Yeah, no, that's that's
coming through.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Granite State.
I love New Hampshire.
-You were -- So, you actually
went to law school, correct?
-Yes. Yes, sir.
-Studied to be a lawyer.
What kind of lawyer
do you think --
If you had not gone into comedy,
what kind of lawyer do you think
you would have been?
-I went to law school
in Australia
and I was, like,
dabbling in, like,
international humanitarian law.
I did, like, a summer program
at Oxford.
And I think if I had graduated,
I would have totally become
a douchebag corporate lawyer.
-Yeah. That's good that you can
admit that about yourself.
-Yeah. Because that's
what it was about.
It was about -- It was about
the money and the power.
But, so, I'm very lucky.
I came this close.
I could, like -- You know,
I was this close to becoming,
like, a Christian management
consultant in Singapore.
-Yeah. And you just --
I mean, it must be a hard track
to jump off and land in comedy.
Like, that is a very
dicey maneuver.
It's incredible
how well it's gone.
-I know.
I'd like to thank the
five Christian Singaporean girls
who rejected me,
and then...
If even one of them
had accepted me as a boyfriend,
I would be in Singapore
as an accountant right now
or something, so thank you.
Thank you to all the women.
-This is a very cool photo
from 2009.
This you and your
then-girlfriend, now wife?
-Yes.
-Who's lovely.
I just met her backstage.
This is you guys
in Times Square.
First time in Times Square?
-First time in Times Square.
This is 2009,
the blurry potato photos,
'cause that's what cameras
were like in 2009, kids.
This was as good as it got,
the resolution.
-This is not user error.
That's just how
good cameras were.
-Yeah. We didn't
mess up the dimensions.
This is what it was.
And, so, first time
in Times Square,
and we took this photo here.
And I just was in love
with New York
and I was like, "I need to come
back here and do comedy."
-And not only did you
come back,
work for "The Daily Show,"
but now you're on tour.
You're going to play Radio City.
And here's a photo
of you guys again.
Ronny Chieng
poster in the background.
Better phone, better camera.
-Better camera. Yeah, yeah.
And it's a dream come true,
so thanks, everyone,
who bought tickets
to the Radio City show.
It's amazing.
-Yeah. Fantastic.
Congratulations on Radio City.
Congratulations on
"The Daily Show."
-Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
-What a pleasure to meet you.
Ronny Chieng, everybody.
For information on his tour,
visit ronnychieng.com.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."